[Music]
there's a concept that's crucial to
chemistry and physics it helps explain
why physical processes go one way and
not the other
why ice melts why cream spreads in
coffee why air leaks out of a punctured
tire it's entropy and it's notoriously
difficult to wrap our heads around
entropy is often described as a
measurement of disorder that's a
convenient image but it's unfortunately
misleading for example which is more
disordered a cup of crushed ice or a
glass of room-temperature water
most people would say the ice but that
actually has lower entropy so here's
another way of thinking about it through
probability this may be trickier to
understand but take the time to
internalize it and you'll have a much
better understanding of entropy consider
two small solids which are comprised of
six atomic bonds each in this model the
energy in each solid is stored in the
bonds those can be thought of as simple
containers which can hold indivisible
units of energy known as quanta the more
energy a solid has the hotter it is it
turns out that there are numerous ways
that the energy can be distributed in
the two solids and still have the same
total energy in each each of these
options is called a microstate for 6
quanta of energy in solid a and 2 in
solid B there are 9702 microstates of
course there are other ways our eight
quanta of energy can be arranged for
example all of the energy could be in
solid a and none in B or half in a and
half in B if we assume that each
microstate is equally likely we can see
that some of the energy configurations
have a higher probability of occurring
than others that's due to their greater
number of microstates entropy is a
direct measure of each energy
configurations probability
what we see is that the energy
configuration in which the energy is
most spread out between the solids has
the highest entropy so in a general
sense entropy can be thought of as a
measurement of this energy spread low
entropy means the energy is concentrated
high entropy means it's spread out to
see why entropy is useful for explaining
spontaneous processes like hot objects
cooling down we need to look at a
dynamic system where the energy moves in
reality energy doesn't stay put it
continuously moves between neighboring
bonds as the energy moves the energy
configuration can change because of the
distribution of microstates there's a
21% chance that the system will later be
in the configuration in which the energy
is maximally spread out there's a 13%
chance that it will return to its
starting point and an 8% chance that a
will actually gain energy again we see
that because there are more ways to have
dispersed energy and high entropy than
concentrated energy the energy tends to
spread out that's why if you put a hot
object next to a cold one the cold one
will warm up and the hot one will cool
down but even in that example there is
an 8% chance that the hot object would
get hotter why doesn't this ever happen
in real life it's all about the size of
the system our hypothetical solids only
had six bonds each let's scale the
solids up to 6,000 bonds and 8,000 units
of energy and again start the system
with three-quarters of the energy in a
and 1/4 in B now we find that the chance
of a spontaneously acquiring more energy
is this tiny number familiar everyday
objects have many many times more
particles than this the chance of a hot
object in the real world getting hotter
is so absurdly small it just never
happens ice melts cream
mixes in and tires deflate because these
states have more dispersed energy than
the originals
there's no mysterious force nudging the
system towards higher entropy it's just
that higher entropy is always
statistically more likely that's why
entropy has been called times arrow if
energy has the opportunity to spread out
it will
[Music]
you